hi everyone
welcome to the webinar hosted by minicor
sigma
my name is cindy chan i'm a scientist in
an r d
group that has been designing creating
and launching various
microscopic cell culture device and
plates for
lifestyle imaging today we're going to
talk about the cellulosic onyx 2
microfluidic platform
and how we use it to capture real-time
high quality images
on growing yeast and bacterial colonies
during
the experiments
and here's just an overview of what
we're going to cover today
first we're going to talk about why it
is important to do lifestyle imaging
then i introduced the motor fluid
platform and how we use it
lastly we're going to talk about the
applications and what types of
experiments you can perform
using the system
so why do we want to do lifestyle
imaging there are tons of
endpoint avails available in the market
these days
and they surely give us some important
data to understand how sales work
but more and more researchers don't find
them sufficient enough
to draw any conclusions because they
don't see the full picture
for example there's a sale right there
at time zero
and still there 24 hours later does it
mean the cells didn't move at all
or maybe it moved for a while and then
moved back
just because you didn't see it move
didn't mean it didn't move
at all correct so how can we
see everything that happens in one
experiment
the answer is lifestyle imaging
so it allows us to answer questions like
when the temporal information so what
were cells doing before and
after the certain time points
and how did cells respond minutes after
the treatment is it a fast response
or a slow response when were proteins of
interest
expressed and then it also helped us
ask questions regarding the the spatial
information like the where
question where were proteins of interest
expressed
was it was the protein shuttling back
and forth between nucleus and cytok
cytoplasm also questions like how
how does the dynamic environment affect
biology
did all cells respond to the treatment
in the same way
the cells recover after the treatment
how and when did they recover
this is all important information to
help us view the big picture
and simple life cell imaging can help us
with that
so take autophagy in mammalian cells as
an example
when we start the cells they will form
these micro vesicles called autovegasm
to recycle the waste and to rebuild
proteins that will help them survive
through difficult times
like these videos clips on the left is
the control group
where cells are normal in normal medium
you wouldn't see the accumulation of the
autophagosomes
and on the right is when cells are
starving
in pbs you see more and more green dots
appear
at 40 minutes into the starvation
you see when and where they are formed
and by using lifestyle imaging
you're confident to say yes the cells
respond to starvation
and also the autophagy kicks in within
one minute
of starvation treatment
and now we use hypoxia as the stress
source
this time to initiate autophagy itself
then you plot the fluorescence intensity
over time in a chart and find different
dynamics in the cellular responses
and based on the piece of the data you
find that
at one point if you stretch the cells
with autophagy inhibitor
like chloroquine in this case and
prevent cells from
recycling and rebuilding the cells would
be so
stressed that even normoxia couldn't
bring the cells back to the normal state
these are all the findings endpoint 88
cannot
provide
here's another example of light cell
imaging experiments
so you grow mammalian cells on our
device in this case it's the human
colorectal
adrenal carcinoma ht29 cell line
and then you introduce the invasive e
coli to study when
and where the invasion occurs in this
case ht29 is stressed
by the invasive bacteria within 6
hours and that eventually wrapped her 15
minutes after the treatment
without light cell imaging you wouldn't
know how fast the invasion would take
place
so now we all agree lifestyle imaging is
important and it gives
you both spatial and temporal
information that endpoint
issues don't provide but how do we do
lifestyle imaging for cell cultures
you'll need a cell culture device to
hold your cells
you also need temperature and gas
control to keep cells healthy
for the images you'll need a microscope
there are some products out there to do
this but they're
huge and often expensive they basically
put a microscope in the incubators
but let's just say you don't care about
the size
and the price tag there's still
limitations
for example for a giant incubator like
this it takes six to eight hours to
reach equilibrium
after it reaches equilibrium you would
have to put the cells into the
incubators by
opening and closing the incubator doors
finger crossing that
by opening and closing the door the gas
content would remain the same
and some lifestyle imaging systems
allowed you to treat yourself
during your experiments but the tubing
going in and out of the incubators is
just too difficult to set up
so here comes our unique stylistic onyx
2 lifestyle imaging system
it's pretty small about the size of a
shoebox
it's compact as well it comes with a
reagent control system
a manifold that ensures temperature and
gas control in the cell culture chambers
and then a culture plate to hold
yourself
you load yourself onto the plate hook it
up with the manifold
and then you use your computer to
control the perfusion
gas and temperature and then you use
your microscope software to set up the
time-lapse imaging
under the microscope and then you click
on start
on both the perfusion system and your
computer
and then walked away you come back the
next day
and get data and it's simple at that
so when you set up experiments it's
going to look like this
you have the cell culture play and then
you have cells
and solutions loaded to the designated
wells
you hook it up with the manifold that
connects to the system
then you use the software to control the
pressures on the cell inlet well
so when the pressure is on the media or
the cell solutions
in that well is going to root through
the micro channels and go into the cell
culture chambers
this is how you load the cells or treat
the cells
once you're happy with the loading
results you can then set up the temp
treatment time the gas
and temperature on the onyx software
place the plate on the microscope and
use your microsoft software
to set up capturing intervals automate
autofocusing setting up beacon etc
and then press start on the onyx system
and also press start on the microscope
catch
capture button and now the system is
going to trick yourself
change gap content or change temperature
at certain time points all by
itself while your microscope is taking
pictures on the cell
the even more unique feature is that we
offer a wide range of microfluidic
plates
for different applications we have a
million plates
which allow you to culture mammalian
cells and then you can flow in bacteria
like the past host pathogen experiments
we previously talked about
we have eat plates and bacteria plates
that are designed
specifically to hold these microbes in
place over time
but no matter what plate type it is they
all have a standard 96 well plate frame
there are four units on each plate so
that you can use one as the control
and do three other experiments
do three other treatments in sd
experiment groups
there are six upstream reservoirs and
the bottom is cover slip glass
that is compatible with most of the
inverted microscopes
let's focus on the yeast and bacteria
plates we launched couple years ago
the main feature of these plates is that
there is
an elastic pdms layer on the top of the
cell culture chambers
when you load the cells with high flow
of media it pushes the seaming to the
top
when loading is done the ceiling drops
to certain heights
but narrow enough to gently hold the
cells in place
then even there's perfusion media flow
the cells will still remain in one focal
plane there are three tier ceilings
on y4c ranging from 3.5
4.5 to 5 micron y4d
ceilings are taller ranging from
5 six to seven micron four deploy cells
b4a ceiling heights ranging from 0.7.9
1.1 1.2 micron
so no matter what size your microbes are
they'll be trapped under one of the
tiered
ceilings and be holding place for the
entire time
without this trapping mechanism if
you're just taking an image on cells
cultured on other pads or on glass
slides
you simply cannot capture a shot that is
in focus
let alone monitoring the expressed or
labor proteins
in real time and that is definitely an
issue onyx
let's take a look at how researchers use
our y4c
plate here's a clip from one of our
customers
in japan used y4c plate to study
mechanisms
behind chromosomes and plasma dna
dynamics in the cell
they are also interested in monitoring
how cells form their
shapes
here's another testimonial another
researcher
professor springer at harvard use onyx
y4c plates to stimulate cells with two
treatments and see how cells decide what
to do
also they use the system to heat shock
the cells and see genes
turning on and off during perturbation
let's he hear him explain in his own
words
we're interested in how cells respond to
heterogeneous environments
so typically when we do things we have
we change media but
it has both input one and input two
there but we wanna see times if we have
like input one on one side of the cell
and input two on the other side of the
cell
how does it integrate that decision and
is it integrated differently than when
the cell
is is faced with a mixture of those two
inputs across the host cell
on some level nothing that we discovered
that we probably couldn't have
discovered a lot of hard work in another
way
but it would allow us to really test
some things out and do things like and
cleanly answer some questions that would
have been difficult otherwise
and the two things that we got that were
probably most interesting that would
have been extremely difficult otherwise
was doing a heat perturbation of a cell
where we were able to look at the
expression level of individual
genes on a single cell basis before the
shock
and how that correlates with growth rate
or response to the shock
and in switching between different media
conditions switching between
a certain glucose galactose regime to
another regime and looking at the
response to the cells and their growth
based on the genomic
character of the strain and also its
current expression level so those are
things that
it would have been extremely extremely
challenging for us to do in any
other way and we're able to get some
pretty interesting exciting results by
using the
slowly sexuality system for that
another good application example is this
clip
where our customers professor garner at
hubber
talked about their research they use
onyx bacteria plate to study how cells
form different shapes under different
stress sources
there hear him explain his research
so what the cellulasic system lets us do
is a couple things first off
it lets us actually follow uh the shape
of the bacteria throughout time
and so we can look at the same cells
over and over over a very long period
so it allows us a constant perfusion of
media the other thing that's really
useful is that what it lets us do
is rapidly insult the bacteria that is
rapidly add antibiotics
or environmental stresses or even turn
on and off individual genes and watch
for example
how bacteria can gain shape or lose
shape so for example
we have cells now which grow without any
shape they're basically amorphous blobs
and we can turn on given genes to
actually reinduce rod shape and watch
these blobs spit out rod shaped cells
and we're watching the enzymatic motions
of these processes as the cells are
re-emerging
so basically what the cell is machine
lets us do is very
rapidly turn on and off conditions or
insults
to individual things while following
singles
besides y4c y4d and b4a plate
we have launched another unique plate
for the east customers last year
y04t so besides the elastic ceiling
we add three elastic wall features
to for a trap to hold e cells for up to
12 hours and more let's look at the
trapping mechanism pictures on the right
when the cells are loaded with high flow
of media the cells will get randomly
trapped in one of the traps
this is specifically useful if you're
studying aging
and folk just want to focus on the
mother cells
or if you just want to study how long
they can keep generating daughter cells
it also becomes very useful if you want
to study mother daughter interactions
let's see the real trapping and culture
in action
in the video on the left it shows how
loading is done
you see individual heat cells gathering
around the chambers
and get randomly trapped in individual
traps
and in the photo shown on the right of
the slide you see the results of a
colony grown
from one single mother cell in our clay
after 24 hours of culture
and the special feature is that we
design the chambers in a way
that the flow can easily wash away the
excess cells so now the culture can go
up to 72 hours without clogging the
nutrient
or the treatment flow
and here's our newest plate
b04f launched early this year
that is specifically designed for
biofilm studies
there are two 200 micron by 200 micron
paths in one unit
because of the elastic pad design the
inner ring of the biofilms will always
be
in molar layer and in one focal plane so
that no matter how many millions of
cells are around
you can still clearly see the proteins
of interest get turned on
or off by turbidation perturbation
inside the bowel zone and because there
are only two paths with
significant spacing in between you can
study the communications
between the two biosomes that are some
distance apart
and we're confident to say that c zero
for f
is the one and only biofilm plate that
allow you
to image two biofilms at the same time
and it's the only lifestyle imaging
system that enables you to monitor the
communications between the two biofilms
here's the clap to show facilities
growing into a biofilm on our plate
as i mentioned in the previous slide the
inner ring of the biofilms are held in
one focal plane throughout the entire
culture
and we also observe the size of the
biofilm changes over time
which is also known as the periodic
growth of the biofilm
the size changes of the biofilm or the
so-called periodic
growth was identified by several
scientists
one of them was professor seoul at ucsd
he was able to use our previous
prototype to trap
and grow biofilms and introduce
environmental perturbation
and observe that biosome could grow and
reorganize and grow
again and reorganize again if you may
take this gene to remove the protein
the size wouldn't change he published a
paper on nature
and linked this protein with biofilm
periodic growth
he also published another nature paper
using our system to study the membrane
potential changes in the biofilms upon
perturbation
during the making of this biofilm plate
dr seoul and his team
have helped us identify the must-have
features
they also helped validate the function
of this plate
and now this play is commercially
available
there are many applications you can do
on our plate
like protein translocation protein
trafficking you can
track certain protein smoothies in the
cell
in the cell walls we can heat shock the
cells or introduce drugs
stress or gas change and see genes
turning on and off
you can study mitosis and how cells
divide
and we have many many customers that
have published on
nature on sale
and great journal and we hope your
papers will be on our list
in the near future as well
so this is it for this webinar if you're
interested in a product
please reach out to our fuel specialist
or go to our website at
miniportsigma.com
to request a demo thank you for your
attention